[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
uh very special episode today i'm a huge
horror fan ryan you know that i know
yeah i'm a big fan and uh i got to work
with this guy
in a movie called urban legend which
many of you probably didn't see
but my dog dies they put it in the
microwave
in the movie real dark stuff oh god yeah
uh but
uh it was great working with him it was
really fun we got to do a little
fangoria magazine interview robert
england of course
freddy krueger uh this is a great
interview i really was waiting for this
one i tried to get him for a long time
and uh he finally
came around maybe he didn't know you
know what to say
uh you just got vaccinated i did i got
my second van second vac
so we could hug soon we can two weeks
two weeks you'll hug me i will guys you
need to watch this
podcast just to see us hug on the show
uh couple reminders first of all thank
you for subscribing
and listening to the show and if you're
here to listen to robert england your
big horror fan i
would really uh hope that you would give
the show a chance and subscribe
you can subscribe at ryan
well you can go to youtube and you can
subscribe type inside of you with
michael rosenbaum and subscribe there
you can watch the
interviews or you can go to spotify or
apple or whatever write a review
subscribe and uh the handles are
inside of you pod on twitter at
insiderviewpodcast on instagram and
facebook
yes there you go i might still be a
little brain foggy yeah i'm a little
brain foggy too
i'll tell you what we watched uh i've
been really getting into these ufos
the ufo thing uh you know i watched the
bob lazar
documentary on netflix it's free i
watched the it's called the phenomenon
which is one of the best documentaries
about ufos and
the military and the government hiding
all this [ __ ] and um
unacknowledged and read some stuff
and listened to the joe rogan interview
and check it out there's uh
there's some stuff going on i think
there's uh i think everybody
at this point knows that there's
probably we're not the only ones
in this vast universe yeah so just check
it out uh
anyway look guys uh we're doing another
show sun spin my band
uh last saturday of every month and it
is the 29th i believe
in may two shows 2 p.m 6 p.m just go to
sunspin.com
you can get merch you could book uh
zooms with us
you could uh book the band and you could
also
uh get tickets to the show which is may
29th
and uh we're really loving it check us
out on spotify2
and uh apple wherever you want to look
but we're all over the place our new
album
we're really excited about it and also
if you want to get uh any merch for
inside of you the podcast if you're
going to go to the inside of your online
store you can get lex luthor stuff
and inside of you stuff and there's just
so much uh good
goodness there's only i think a couple
lunch boxes left uh-oh
smallville lunch boxes but get on it
yeah so
let's have a code let's have a discount
code for the uh
inside of you online store okay let's
call it
ufo 15. 15 off everything in the store
ufo 15. oh my god uh you're going to
watch these documentaries i'm going to
make you watch them so you
then you're going to go you know what i
i know what you're talking about look
here's
i believe that aliens exist
the the rabbit hole is too deep to go
down for me to feel
any kind of sanity about it like it's i
said that
i said the same thing and then i start
watching the stuff and i go
i just i i don't why is it so crazy to
think that
some ship you know that goes lights
light years ahead of us the the the
speed at which these crafts go
somehow whether it broke down whether it
uh had difficulties whether it came into
our realm
our universe and crashed what's so crazy
about that and then
they've got this technological advance
advances and you know that we can't even
understand that
and then for years we're trying to catch
up that's as simple as that it's just
because
there are so many other issues in the
world to fix this one just feels like a
but that's why i fix it this could fix
so much i mean
i have a theory i'm not gonna talk about
it uh anyway thank you guys so much for
uh subscribing i love my patrons you
know i do
means the world to me that you listen to
the podcast
um thank you westwood one thank you ryan
thank you bryce if you want to write in
hello out inside of you podcast
uh i don't always write back but i do
read the messages
and i thank you for them and um
that's about it why don't we get inside
of robert england
it's my point of view you're listening
to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
well what a treat i get to talk to nancy
england
oh yes the infamous nancy oh yeah i mean
how many times have you said how why did
you marry a woman named nancy
we get so much fan mail about that and
she's sort of cut from the same bolt of
cloth
as heather well the joke is that he
looked really hard
right i bet you good
there's so many questions you probably
get just so tired of
and i was thinking okay let me put
myself in in robert's shoes here because
you know i played a villain for a long
time
and you know people would always say
looks luth in fact i had a guy come over
and and redo my wall in the podcast room
and he's like every you know he's this
hispanic guy and a great guy he's like
uh
mr luther mr luther
she's a loser yeah he's like actually he
called me mr lu thorne like
it's actually luther
but i mean do you you go through stages
of like
in the beginning you're like excited and
then you're like all right that's not
the only thing i do
i mean and then you go hey what the hell
i embraces this is amazing i'm lucky to
be did you go through stages like that
of like people going
hey freddy and you're like [ __ ] you well
you know michael i i always thought of
you as
as a comedian and then you
you had this great success playing a
villain
you know so i can kind of flip this
question back to you but for me
i was lucky i had the whole 70s
playing best friends right sidekicks and
then
towards the end i was everybody's
favorite redneck yeah you know what
crash robert england
and uh so i i had done i'd already been
established in holly weird
yeah and knew who i was and when i did
v and then freddie it just
banged me into international actor
overnight you know and i said
i'd never had that kind of success
before
and i just it was like grabbing the ring
on the merry-go-round you know i got it
i
i just hung on yeah cause you had done i
mean you're classically trained you've
done a bunch of [ __ ] before that
so you don't have anything to prove you
know i mean i understudied iago
with a great actor uh playing othello uh
roger robinson the late roger robinson
who did a lot of the august wilson blaze
i think he won a tony award for one of
them but but i i've done a lot of stuff
but i did it in that moment of time you
know when you don't
when you're not on you know
entertainment tonight and access
hollywood
right cover of people magazine because
you're starring in some play
in the midwest with michael moriarty
original law
order but um you know it's
so i had that kind of under my belt
right and i kind of proved to myself
you know that i could do that stuff and
then the first 10 years in hollywood
you know my god i hit my marks with jeff
bridges and
barbra streisand and reynolds and
charles bronson susan sarandon i had a
partial nude scene with susan serrano
what do you mean partial
where you're at was it susan was topless
well what about you no i was playing the
bashful side
oh okay and so i got to be bashful
and uh sensitive and uh and and susan
had to run
button her blouse and flash me have you
ever beard ass
in 1975 that's rocky horror show era
i'm gonna hum and a hummingbird did you
i mean did you ever bare ass or anything
like that
oh yeah yeah i shot recently too and i'm
old and you know my testicles are down
around my kneecaps
come on yeah no a fear clinic i had to
run around naked in chair clinic
so uh and be this old scientist you know
so that was kind of
wait a minute you showed your junk well
i mean i could see it when i i go from
like a kind of
uh samadhi tank you know uh one of those
uh uh
kind of like hot tub sensory deprivation
hot tubs and they kind of
they put a towel around me and march me
across but
you know i went to dailies i saw the
pelotus
you're like somebody's gonna take this
some aid like some little assistant's
gonna just take a picture of your junk
and it's gonna be everywhere what was
that magazine celebrity skin
remember yep i do back in the day don't
you remember you
and me and jonathan silverman back in
the 1960s
hanging out with you hefner at the
playboy mansion oh getting our pictures
in celebrity skin
i think silverman was dating a couple of
girls from petticoat junction
jesus you really are aging him there is
he that old
old silverman i'm just kidding i know i
think it's general
right well listen were you were your
parents when you were growing up because
like
first of all i want to say i love you
i've always loved you
you were an idol of mine and uh you know
working with you in urban legend and
just being in the trailer and i remember
when fangoria magazine came to interview
us
and i just was on cloud nine it was my
first big movie really
uh with a big part and we just really
hit it off
and i just always admired you and looked
up to you and
we got along so fondly that it was just
uh you made it so easy for everybody
around you because you are a legend and
even at that time
you you ordered breakfast at craft
service one day
at the window i think we had really good
craft service like like some fabulous
lesbians from vancouver who were making
us great you know granola with a lot of
brown sugar and
syrup and stuff and i remember you
ordering as mike as as christopher
walken one day
from then on i take x silver easy
scrambled
robert england's with a u it's not an a
it's not land it's lund lunt he's
swedish he's swedish you are swedish but
but i just i wow that's anything i can
do
wow he's just everything's it's relax
and
what's funny is i ended up working with
him like two years later i know
and he saw you after that i asked you
without dueling dueling watkins
yeah dealing walk-ins he was yeah he was
uh kind of uh
weirded out by me but because i was so
you know you get that bright-eyed kind
of young guy looking at him going
and he's like oh great another fanboy
another fanboy but he was cool uh but
you know when i met you you were so
humble we had such a good time and we
that was really a good time shooting
urban legends
it was a great cast i mean you know i've
had a little crush on alicia wit
my entire career i remember her on the
old civil sceptic
sybil shepard show say that ten times
fast but uh
i mean you know jared leto pre-oscar
josh jackson i think the unsung acting
in that movie i mean loretta divine brad
dwarf but the unsung performance in that
movie
rebecca gayhart's great in that movie
yeah she did a great job
what about the guy what about the
professor remember he was from x-files
yeah oh no see i had lunch
the john neville john neville i had when
i was a ratta boy
and i was all patches on my sleeves you
know
and uh talking like madonna in london um
royal academy brad um we studied
some of those performances and john
neville had done
a fellow on the west end with richard
burton
when the entire audience was teenage
girls because burton was so beautiful
you know with his strategic acne scars
and that beautiful voice that sounded
like silver thunder
and and they would all do the matinees
the girls the teenage girls would all
ditch school
go to the matinees to see burton and
neville
and burton would swap roles one night
he'd play othello in blackface
politically incorrect and then the next
night he'd play iago
so i go out to lunch in downtown toronto
at this elegant old restaurant with john
neville and of course i know all this
[ __ ]
so i i start asking him these questions
and no one's asking these questions
in 50 years so it's little robert
england you know
sitting there you know but i you know
i've got my little goatee
and uh and my george clooney haircut and
i'm and i'm being a subtle fanboy with
john neville
but he loved it so i got all this gossip
you know about judy dench and about
richard burton give me something
give me something that nobody knows judy
dench apparently was
wild and helen mirren apparently he said
helen mirren every time she got a
she got on stage she had to take her
clothes off you know she always wanted
to do a nude scene
helen mirren always wanted to be naked
apparently that's what he says when
neville told me he goes oh
oh helen helen she she did king leo
naked if she could
she loved i guess she loved apparently
she had a lot of nude scenes
at the old but when you're naked at the
old villa or the royal shakespeare
company that's really something you know
yeah wow that's pretty amazing i
remember
yeah john neville was great i remember
that one line i just always remember
goes
the weekend the weekend
if you look at if you if you if you like
him it's amazing oh yeah he's done
everything
yeah to see the stuff he did i think he
was sort of the new john gilgood
i think that's sort of how i could see
that yeah
hey when you were a kid and you were
born in glendale i didn't know you were
born in glendale
i was born up in the foothills there you
know there's that place there's a kind
of a weird area where hollywood
and atwater village yep and boulevard
it's sort of like los feliz hits
glendale
and there's some foothills going up and
i was born at a hospital
in those foothills but i almost
immediately became a valley boy i grew
up
almost until i was 18. uh i was in the
valley i was a valley boy
and i lived in encino and and
sherman oaks and woodland hills and
northridge
and i lived for a while on that street
right down this
right down the block from clark gable so
when i was like a little kid
going to the market with my mom clark
gable would be in there you know in the
world
that you always want to do it act i'm
i i remember yeah yeah i remember the
moment i was supposed to be a lawyer but
i remember the moment i was
dragged dragged off to a professional
children's
uh workshop children's theater workshop
and i was with this older girl
who's the hottest girl in the valley and
that's saying something that's a pretty
high bar
you know and she later became a talk
show host in puerto rico
and she was a wannabe actress and i
figured i'd just be you know
sweeping backstage and and
ushering or something i got all the lead
roles i was pinocchio i was peter pan i
was
aladdin i was hansel and hansel and
greta
and gretel and i also got laid for the
first time i was
12 years old with her with the puerto
rican no no no
all i remember was there was a
sweatshirt that said bloomington indiana
on it
it was kids from all over the country so
it was some bad girl from bloomington
indiana how old were you when you got
laid
12 and a half yeah wait wait how old my
summer of 12 and a half well
i didn't have uh penetration sex for a
long time after that but yeah i lost my
12 and a half 12 and a half i didn't
have hair on my balls till i was 18.
i didn't either and i was probably the
worst piece of ass in the world you know
talk about premature ejaculation but uh
or any ejaculation and i had i had
curlers in my hair
they spoolies they had curlers in my
hair the girl had put
my hair was supposed to be curly for one
of the roles i was playing
that's ridiculous that is absolutely
wonderfully ridiculous
a hairdryer fetish now were your parents
were they always
uh supportive of what you were doing and
and just like i love you
i love you robert uh you can't go wrong
with us did you have a good support
system
they formed me out to the to the
children's theater
so i blame them kind of but then later
on they sort of thought i would change
my tune
and and stick with law uh because i was
an
athlete and because i was you know
national thespian guy and because i had
good grades
i was sort of uh fast-tracked
maybe and they invited me up to stanford
you know for a meet you know that thing
you do in the senior senior year you go
to a college
right and i went up there and uh
i was a pretty hardcore surfer and the
the one thing we hated were speedos you
know you had to have surf
board shorts not speedos and i went up
to stanford and all the frat boys were
from all over the country and it was the
first sunny day
uh up in palo alto and they all had
their speedos on and they were laying
out the lawn outside the frat houses
rubbing each other with baby oil to get
a suntan because everybody liked to be
tan
back then we didn't know about skin
cancer and it creeped me out
so i said nah nah so i went to uh
cal state northridge and ucla for a
while you know i just stayed close to
all but they were always like
uh whatever you want to do we love you
like did you get like a lot of love as a
kid
yeah i was great i had a great
upbringing i mean you know it was
it's i look back and it was like i
really encouraged
and uh let me alone and also that kind
of freedom
you know there was my generation we had
tons of freedom you know your
mom or your dad would whistle for you
for dinner yeah yeah i remember that
night yeah and until you were just out
in the neighborhood
and you could tell who was cool by where
people's bicycles were
in the driveways because in those days
nobody parked in driveways
you had to use the garage you know and
the streets were for kids
yeah and orange groves and the beach you
know was for kids you know
i experienced that i experienced that in
the 80s it was just a freedom of like
be home by 10. they didn't know where
you were if you wanted to go see someone
at the movie theater go
i'll meet you there at seven and just
hope they're there yeah
well you also learned a kind of social
interaction and how to survive and
and and it was weird like at strange
points during your
your childhood remember when cool kids
kind of were nice to you the first time
you know or let you come over and hang
their parents were out of town or
something
or you get to go swim in their pool or
or their mom
would drop you off at the beach you know
drop you off at malibu and
leave you there all day and uh so those
moments of time
i think are really important because i
if you if you're not out
on your own you're not able to kind of
negotiate that kind of
social uh demarcation that exists in
society
yeah i think that's really nice you know
i look at your career and you've done so
much i look at tv i love look at the
movies i look at all these things
when you know your parents are seeing
success and they're seeing charlie's
angels
you did charlie's angels how long i've
been around yeah
jesus well i mean that's not that old
that's uh i mean what are you using what
are you
my first film job is 73 but my
my professional debut was 68. how old
were you
20 21. now
your parents when you did now your
parents no longer with you
they've been gone for a while yeah you
know i i wonder
they see all these roles they got to
experience a lot of your success right
yeah they well my mom wasn't around for
a lot of freddy but the very beginning
of freddie
but my dad my dad's great moment was
i was working and i couldn't go to the
premiere of my first movie
because i was out killing burt reynolds
in another movie and so my dad went
to my premiere movie directed by dan
petry the whitest guy in the world
canadian director great director who
directed
among other things the original raisin
in the sun
you know and uh i mean that cast is
who's who of great black actors but
i i didn't get to go to the premiere and
the after party was at jason's
and my dad got to go wow and he was with
pamela sue martin
and jan michael vincent they took care
of it and my dad got to go to the after
party at chase's and my dad's a martini
guy
and jason's is famous for like the best
martini in the world
my dad had been there before uh but not
a lot
so my dad loved that my dad kind of knew
i had arrived because he got to go to
the after party at jason's
and i had single you know the first time
you get single card
at your own table my first movie i got
single cards single card in at the
the you know you have your own table at
the party if there's you know
yeah oh my god yeah fourth billing and
so my dad kind of got it in
and i kept the l i kept you know i'm i
was bobby england robbie england for my
whole life
and i used robert englund uh and that my
dad really made my dad feel good because
that's what my
dad would call me when he was pissed at
me but what was it like
he was like robert robert get your ass
in here
12 and a half years old laying piper
what are you doing get
schwinn out of the driveway but like you
know i have to say like when when i
first got
smallville when they first saw it that
was the first time they were like
oh you're on a successful show like i
had done a lot of things that weren't
successful but that was
you know but this was the biggest thing
this was like holy [ __ ] so nightmare
yeah and all of a sudden you know it was
like everybody
was like wait a minute it's not just
another independent film or a little
you know my dad always said what are you
doing i'm doing this movie uh when's it
gonna be in theaters well it's
independent oh so it's not real
well no it could become a movie can you
go to the top
yeah it always just somehow lessened it
made me feel
lesser than i was but we won't get into
that but uh
you know but i wonder when they first
saw a nightmare on elm street and they
saw you
as not playing the buddy not playing
these you know the plays and
all that stuff was great and they're
like this guy our son's talented but
when they
saw you as this this come to life this
larger-than-life character
did they ever did your mom or dad ever
just say
wow robert did they ever have that
moment they never saw me on stage
uh you know professionally which was a
great
disappointment because i had a couple of
big successes uh on stage but
johnny carson i think did a freddy
krueger joke
or or or dick cavett or somebody right
joke and they heard that and uh
and i'd sort of entered the popular
culture by then
and there was also on the sunday funnies
some one of the cartoonists in the
sunday papers had done a freddy krueger
thing
and that's actually what sort of
rel that sort of relaxed them you know
wow but i had also done v v was a big
show
and it was a mini series yeah and it was
a big event
and it had this really rare uh
advertising campaign
like rosemary's baby when i was
in college in ucla hanging out all over
the streets of westwood
there were stencils that said pray for
rosemary's baby
and fake graffiti that said pray for
rosemary's baby so we were all
anticipating it if you hadn't read the
book
by ireland you know you were what what
is this rosemary's baby it's coming it's
coming and
or you just see an entire billboard and
it was just
a a baby's bassinet you know
or a baby carriage yeah creepy uh so
they did the same thing with v
they did fragrant fake graffiti
like dripping graffiti like graffiti had
a big v right
a big v and it was dripping like red red
spray paint everywhere all over america
on billboards and my parents saw that
and i had already told him i was doing
it so they knew that was sort of like
oh you know and also and you you know
this i mean
because you've done a lot of
independence you get that tv money that
first tv check
you forget that's where the bucks are
yeah tv and syndication that's where you
make your money
that's how you buy your first house yeah
and i couldn't believe it you know
getting those first checks from v
uh you know i thought i was like whoa
you know
after a month you know you you're maybe
you've got six figures in the bank you
can't believe it you know
and that was mark singer right v mark
and
faye grant and i i saw faye grant
singing in the rain on broadway she's so
good
yeah a lot of people michael uh uh uh
michael ironside
the great michael ironside yeah within
that yeah it was a huge cast
uh uh michael wright uh just terrific
actors yeah
that's awesome i mean we got those guys
that became
ilm um john dykstra
from from star wars and they came over
and did our effects and so the special
effects on v
were what really raised the bar for
special effects on television
you look back at it now and and it looks
kind of like
cheesy cgi but back then it was state of
the art
right and uh really but before v
it was just somebody running around in
green makeup chasing william shatner
inside of you is brought to you by helix
sleep
nobody needs a a good bad more than i do
ryan you have back problems i know and
yeah a lot of surgeries
a lot of a lot of problems and uh
i struggle and it's very important to
have a good mattress something that you
feel
comfortable with that you wake up in the
morning and feel refreshed because the
day is going to be a little tough anyway
if you get back problems or if you get
any kind of problem
so uh i really find that helix sleep
allows me to have a sleep and feel
refreshed in the morning
and uh i need it you're talking to
someone who
does suffer helix sleep has a quiz that
takes just two minutes to complete
and matches your body your body type and
sleep preferences
to the perfect mattress for you why
would you buy a mattress made for
someone else
you wouldn't do that with helix you're
getting a mattress that you know will be
perfect for the way
you sleep everybody's unique and helix
knows that so they have several
different mattress bottles to choose
from they have soft
medium i have the medium and firm
mattresses mattresses great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot and even a
helix
plus mattress for plus size sleepers so
it's pretty easy if you're looking for a
mattress
you just take the quiz you order the
mattress that you're matched to
and the mattress comes right to your
door shipped for free you don't ever
need to go
to a mattress store again and boy does
that make me feel good
helix is awesome but you don't need to
take my word for it helix was awarded
the number one best overall mattress
pick
of 2020 and by gq and wired magazine
just go to helix sleep h-e-l-i-x
helix sleep dot com slash inside take
their two-minute quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10-year
warranty and you get to try it out for a
hundred nights
risk-free 100 nights 100 nights that's
pretty good you get to try it free for
100 nights to see if it works this is
your life folks your life
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but you will
hmm sounds pretty good they'll pick it
up free if you don't
come on it's it's right there for you
come on helix is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
sleep dot com slash inside
that's helix sleep.com inside
for up to 200 off and two free
pillows inside of you is brought to you
by better help
better help online therapy it is may's
mental health awareness month and
throughout june
inside of you is proud proud to join the
cause
of destigmatizing therapy
i talk about it all the time we are in a
world where
we need therapy therapy has become part
of the norm i believe or at least it
should be part of the norm
a lot of people don't know what therapy
is ryan therapy is whatever you want it
to be
if you want to go in and talk to someone
objectively a professional
someone who will walk you through things
and
um you know that could be therapy if you
just want to get things off your chest
if you have depression issues if you
have anxiety i i for one i feel anxious
all the time
so we talk about that we talk about why
i feel anxious and
when you could put it into a place where
it makes more sense
um and understand your your anxiety or
whatever it is you're going through
it makes life a lot easier and a lot of
times we don't understand
what we're dealing with and we just know
something's wrong
and so now is a great time with may's
mental health awareness month
um and throughout june to to
destigmatize therapy
and get some therapy better help will
assess your needs and match you with
your own
licensed professional you can start
communicating
in 48 hours under 48 hours pretty crazy
like this it's not a crisis line it's
not self-help it's professional
counseling done
securely online therapists have a broad
range of expertise that may
not be locally available in your area
but the services available for clients
worldwide
login to your account anytime send a
message to your counselor
you can schedule a weekly video phone or
even live
chat sessions if you don't want to be
seen on video you don't have to you
could talk
you could text if you like better help
is committed
to facilitating great therapeutic
matches so
it makes it easy and free to change
counselors if
needed it's more affordable than
traditional offline counseling and
financial aid
is available i'll tell you that's the
truth you go to a therapist in los
angeles or wherever you're gonna be
charged hundreds of dollars
for uh an hour if you get an hour um
better help is significantly
more affordable so many people have been
using betterhelp that they're recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
it's the thing to do may's mental health
awareness month and
throughout june remember we are
destigmatizing
therapy so go get some therapy talk to
somebody
help yourself out you owe it to be the
best you
our listeners get 10 off their first
month of online therapy at
betterhelp.com
inside that's betterh-e-l-p-com
slash inside
you know you said something about star
wars the star wars guy did you did you
audition for star wars
you know it's the it's this internet uh
uh yeah they throw that out there
well it's the internet screws up it's
like that dixie cup
with a string in it the way they uh kind
of obstruct the truth
no i have a great uh once upon a time in
hollywood story
that i tell it conventions and it got
turned into robert england was up for
star wars i was i wanted to go in
and audition for the frederick forest
role in apocalypse now
the chef right i was too young
and freddie forrest was under contract
to the zodiac trope
but i got in for the surfer because
i had done big wednesday because i surf
so they brought me in for the surfer
they thought i was a little bit too old
i had
kind of you know stubbly beard but i was
buff i was
tan i was surfing i had long blonde hair
and i was wearing kind of a military
uh thrift shop outfit apocalypse now
right
i think i even had a pair of fake dog
tags on my shirt unbuttoned
long blonde curly hair and fred's
fred bruce or somebody walked me across
the hall
from the apocalypse now audition which
which i did not get
they said you know you might be right
for something here and they brought me
over to the star wars audition
and i don't even think it was called
star wars then
and they took my polaroid like a mug
shot
you know profile and full face and i
think it was for the han solo role
i think they didn't they didn't know how
to go with it originally they were
thinking of an older
uncle the kind of guy that brings a
joint to thanksgiving
and gets all the kids high you know the
cool older uncle and then
and i think they even offered it to tom
seller i think i heard
and he turned them down or something i
don't know but anyway he turned it down
for rev
for a reverse mortgage
yeah back in the day little annie's
husband passed away she loved her house
though she didn't want to lose her house
anyway
i've i've been around the block saying
my first rodeo anyway
i go across the hall and it's and and
i'm
just excited because i love george lucas
american graffiti
thx 138 i love george lucas i go across
the hall i take my polaroid maybe for
han solo but i notice the sides for luke
skywalker
because the name it's such a great name
luke skywalker and
i looked at the sides i can't remember
if i stole them or not
i went across the street to the formosa
so now you know where i am oh yeah had a
couple of bushmills
jumped in my old 2000 datsun
not year 2000 cubic inches and i went
went back to my place in laurel canyon
and i look outside there's a pair of
old beat up fry boots in front of my
front door which means ah
it's mark hamill because we would take
off our shoes i had nice carpeting in my
my lair up in laurel canyon and uh
mark was on my couch watching the bob
newhart show
we would watch bob newhart and mary
tyler moore
because we hadn't watched the originals
then we'd call our agents
and i walked in the door and i said hey
mark you know you george lucas is doing
another movie
and you might be right for this so my my
once upon a time in hollywood story
is that freddy krueger told luke
skywalker
to call his agent and he got the part
you know he got in there and got the
part
now his agent hates me telling this
story because she swears that
she already had submitted him but i
don't know of course
this is before your time but in the 70s
you were either movies or you were tv
you didn't go back and forth
until travolta oh yeah um until welcome
back cotter
and then he went into saturday night
fever right that was a big shift that
was a big shift you were either a movie
guy
or a tv guy and your agents had power
accordingly
you know to that and even then it was
tough even after that it didn't really
start to happen until like even
i'd say even really in 2000's like you
know it was tricky i mean you were
either a tv actor or you were a movie
actor it was it was very different yeah
wow what a great story so you and you
and mark hamill were close
mark was turned me onto the kinks he
turned me on to
lenny bruce all the lenny bruce albums
lord buckley
uh but best of all uh was monty python
and we had all the albums and i did for
like a year i didn't realize they
performed that stuff
actually performed at a sketch comedy i
just thought they were like
bbc radio voices and we would lay on our
backs
you know and look at the ceiling in my
apartment and just
play the albums over and over again and
try to memorize the routines we love
monty python
mark hamill in real life is just really
really quick
really funny he is you know he go he
works a little blue
you know oh yeah it's different than you
think you know because he's so he was so
good-looking
he was always sort of like leading man
yeah but he's actually i think a
character actor
couple i know a lot of people are like
that richard gere is maybe you know he's
such a good looking guy but
he might actually really be a character
actor in a leading man's body i think it
happens
occasionally to some of these guys did
you have where you know you and mark are
good friends and then
because this happens all the time he
goes off to do star wars he becomes a
big star and then you don't hear from
him again
no mark came back and told us all the
stories
did he say this is going to suck wait
oh mark knew because mark's a fan boy
you know mark
mark had a had a letter in famous
monsters magazine
as a child you know i think he was a
military brat and
uh mark knew uh that it was gonna be
huge
and i got he told me you know alec
guinness stories and i think he had a
crush on carrie fisher
and no mark and i were friends after
that for
for a while what changed was i moved
i moved to santa monica i had some money
after i think it was after stay hungry
and we moved to santa monica or
i i moved some mark mark moved or mark
moved to malibu and i moved to hancock
park
and we i we just that was like you know
we just didn't see each other as much
anymore mark got married
uh and that that's sort of like when we
do i would see him occasionally at
you know like uh comic-con down in san
diego
right and star wars was 78
76 yeah 77 78 yeah
and and and nightmare and elm street was
what 80 84. yeah i was just still i was
doing
i think i was doing uh my henry fonda
movie then
right right around then yeah did you
when you auditioned do you remember the
scene you auditioned for for freddie
i it was a meet i didn't read
you met with wes nope it was a meet uh
and it was i think it was
in north hollywood but it might have
been at the studio the old desi lou
studio on goenga
but uh i i again i was like surfing then
when i wasn't acting i was just surfing
so i was really really tan
and i had really long blonde hair and my
hair is
is kind of fine and thin and i remember
greasing my hair back using some oil
under the hood of my car
and i've told this story a million times
i'm sorry if i'm boring anything no
no i haven't heard it and i also use
cigarette ash
under my eyes it's an old makeup theater
trick
it looks very real you can make your
eyes look real heroin
chic kind of junky you can sync your
eyes a bit
and to kind of counteract my healthy my
healthy malibu tan
and i grease my hair back and you can
kind of see through my hair to see my
skull a little bit
because my hair was greased and slicked
back and
uh my hairline's high anyway and i went
in
and i just remember keep your mouth shut
robert
keep your mouth shut and i
i played staring games with wes
i tried not to blink you know that old
thing when you're a kid you don't try
not to blink who can go longest without
blinking
and wes was the rack on tour wes was
telling me
all of his ideas about the movie and
what it meant and
how it would be and i listened and
absorbed that
but i kind of posed a little bit i kind
of sucked my cheeks in
and i kind of made my eyes a little bit
psycho and i think that's how i got the
part but annette benning i don't know if
you went up for
national lampoon movies or stuff with
annette benning but annette benning
i had just been up for national
lampoon's class reunion every role in
the movie
i tested with everybody annie potts i
tested with everybody
and i didn't get it i kind of canceled
myself out
uh with my being too versatile or
something i don't know
and but i net felt bad about that and i
think annette was really my champion
and and and convinced wes uh annette
benning annette benson benson jesus
christ
ned benson not in that benny not the
actress okay
that's me that's a that's a mind fart i
apologize everybody's like
no annette benson uh was the casting
director she did a lot
a lot she's quite famous and i think she
really fought for me
but there's another theory that i have a
real skinny kind of
hatchet face and they were very worried
bob shea head of new line west grave and
they were all worried
david miller the makeup effects guy
about when you put makeup on somebody
a lot of times that they have a big head
and a lot of people in film have big
heads because it looks great on film
small people with big heads you know
what i'm talking about i have a big head
thank you you put makeup on and
prosthetics
then their heads really look big
especially if they don't have broad
shoulders
right well i'm 5 10 and i've got
reasonably broad children so i could
take the prosthetics
without it looking out of ratio to the
rest of my body
and i think it could have been as simple
as that although i hadn't done any tests
or anything
they may have just been able to tell by
the way i looked did you think you were
gonna like oh they're gonna fire me once
they see makeup on there's always this
this actor thought of like they're gonna
fire me once no no you know
it was it was a strange thing i kind of
owned it quick
i mean wes didn't give me much direction
from
after about the first couple of days i
just sort of got it
he knew i i knew that freddie exists in
a dream so it's a little larger than
life
you're dreaming freddy he's not walking
around in an alley sharing a cigarette
with you behind the formosa
freddy's freddy's in your dream so it's
slightly exaggerated
you know freddy could break into song
and dance if he wanted to
and he kind of knows your subconscious
he's kind of in there
looking in your underwear drawer of your
subconscious and knowing what makes you
tick
so i kind of got that right away and wes
just sort of left me alone and he liked
the way i physicalized it
and i was sort of set free i had done
like
a year and a half straight of television
and you know michael
how many times at the end of the day
they light you for
45 minutes and stick you in a corner and
you just have to listen
to somebody else's monologue right and
they just need you're going to only use
three seconds of that yeah but you stand
there for a half hour
trying to look cool you know and uh uh
you know
i was so freed from that wearing the
makeup and getting to physicalize
uh i felt very liberated i was able to
move more
kind of dance the guy yeah what was your
first line that you remember and you
didn't
you're like how am i going to deliver
this what am i did you know did you
rehearse it a million times in front of
the mirror
no you know i found the voice putting
the makeup on
really that's when you found the voice
yeah and i think the first line i had
was just saying the name of the girl
tina
and i think i did it a lot of different
ways but i wanted to do it with a
whisper
tina you know i had this idea of it as a
dot dot dot you know i could sort of see
it mentally
and uh i think that was my first line
though i found
the voice sitting out in the valley
deep valley you know borderline
pacoima north hollywood and i was in a
garage at david miller the great david
miller's makeup shop
and and in an old vintage 1950s 1940s
barber chair
in front of the mirrors and maybe this
was the second or third time we did a
makeup test
and david wasn't real his hygiene with
his brushes wasn't real good
they would get kind of stiff and crusty
you know like day old snot
and he was kind of like touching me up
because wes
or bob shearer both of them were coming
over to to look at the makeup and give
him notes
and he was kind of stabbing me with his
crusty brush and i think i went
something like
goddamnit david and i i saw myself say
goddammit david
in the mirror and the reason i said that
was i was a little horse or
something or i hadn't had my morning
coffee and i went
oh hey i kind of like that that that
gutterly plays voice work
so i had the voice from that yelling at
david miller
one day you know that is you know
freddie's talking like this i'm saying
hey
what are we gonna you know he's trying
to he wants to listen to heavy metal
music in the morning and i want to watch
the today show let's watch the today
show
you know i like that jane polly hey you
know and uh
that's my voice you know surfing usa
robert england from the valley right and
uh
i can't use my broader voice my long
vowels don't work at all
so i i found that voice yelling and
scolding david miller at
like eight in the morning somewhere you
know
in east bum [ __ ] north hollywood uh
you know in a garage in a barber's chair
it was seeing it come out of that face
in the mirror
god damn it david i just love that i did
it
wait a minute thank you david what
you're [ __ ] you're crazy
i know yes i mean you know i watched the
documentary it was like a
i don't know eight parts whatever series
of of the whole nightmare down the
street and i watched it and it was just
like
you know they kind of let you run free
after a while because you would come up
with all this stuff i mean i mean a lot
of those things you were
you know like welcome to prime time
[ __ ] was your line right
that's yeah but i i in all fairness to
the writers and there's some great
writers it's like who's who
guy that wrote shawshank redemption you
know we have great writers on the show
forest major a lot of great people and
uh
and of course wes ryan hegeland you know
but you know what happens you know in
smallville
about halfway through season two maybe
sooner for you michael
but about halfway through season two you
know you get you have your house
directors
on a series and then you have you know
because of the dga
you have to have new directors every so
many episodes
and you know every once in a while you
get a new director and he's probably not
a real big super boy fan right you know
he wants
he likes terrance malek he wants to
follow lex luthor
with a handheld steady cam between his
legs
walking you know up the stairs and and
and they don't that's not something he's
not paying attention to the plot he
doesn't know who you really like
who you don't like and he makes you
stand next to somebody you don't like or
he wants you to do something a piece of
business with a prop that you know
as michael rosenbaum you know he
wouldn't do that lex luthor wouldn't
wouldn't drink a beer out of a bottle
you know right it's not lex luthor he
drinks you know 25 year old scotch out
of crystal
right and you just know that about the
character
well you own it there comes a point
where even you know more than the
writers
about the do's and don'ts of lex luthor
and then the same thing happened with me
with freddie there comes a point where i
just sort of owned it
you know rennie harlan the director
ronnie harland who really let me alone
on part four
and that's my favorite performance uh uh
of of of freddie because he really let
me kind of
dance the character a bit you know right
really make him reptilian
kind of wear the furniture yeah i mean
you just
you could just tell you were having more
and more fun i remember
the the audience even like even during
the whole run of all the uh
the um the movies i remember forcing my
mom well i didn't force my mom she loved
horror movies and got me to watch
horror movies with her when i was eight
so that's why i'm kind of [ __ ] up
but um we're watching the one where i
believe it's dream warriors
and i remember somebody in the audience
just jumped up and goes
that's freddie's mama
helena krueger and i was i remember
going wow
man people are excited about this movie
still
well you know there's a great happy
accident
and and i'm sure it's happened to you
with some cult films
video for me would have been dvd for you
michael
but i came of my career came of age
during the video revolution so i had hit
movies in the theaters
and then they became hip hip hip films
again when they came out in video to a
whole other audience
yep but i had that times eight
and that's not counting the tv series
and not only do i have that
times eight but then i have it again
with dvd
and blu-ray and cable and
and marathons on cable so you get a new
generation
yeah i'm on my third generation of fans
so what you're saying is you're rich
the movie had a 20-year run it was 84
84-94
and then 10 years went away and then we
did freddie versus jason
and that revived that revived it again
for a new generation so we actually had
a 20-year run
eight movies a television series jesus
man
and dvd and videos and ever and then the
videos became the making of and then the
tvs became blu-ray
you know and uh and and they became more
sophisticated
now people aren't doing that anymore but
now people i i was i've been looking
like on the subset of menus on a
streaming app the other day
and i couldn't believe it it was there
was like a robert england section
you know of just horror movies you know
how cool is that god i've done you know
in europe you know
of you is brought to you by geico gotta
love geico guys if you don't have uh if
you don't have this uh new bundling
policy that they've got
it makes it so much easier on you and uh
you know we're all lazy we've got things
to do in our lives geico makes life
a little easier ryan we know your rent
your place
again i got the rent and you get your
mortgage you're right and you got auto
yeah you pay for your car insurance all
that but instead of going and writing a
check to this guy or that guy
and this what if i just said this
bundling policy you could just write one
check
for all of it that would save me so much
time it would save you so much time it's
just easy
i mean don't you want to make life
easier especially in the last year we
got to make life easier come on
we just go to geico.com we get a quote
and you see how much you could save it's
geico easy folks
visit geico.com today that's geico.com
even a rosenbomb can do it inside of you
is brought to you by
charlie bear of got pet products
my dog blanche loves good dog food i
think
everybody who has an animal don't you
think they should have give them really
good
food i agree not just cheap crap that
you get at a grocery store
kirkland brand dogs they just want to
get it off the
yeah exactly uh these guys um at got
they make wonderful wonderful products
and their charlie bear treats are just
delicious irv loved it
god bless them and now blanche loves it
the hound gatos
they just go crazy they have to have it
every day and night they come in so many
different flavors you know if you're
going to feed yourself a nice meal
you'd owe it to your dog like right here
blanche
that's blanche and she loves this stuff
and if i give her anything else
she turns her head so charlie bear
treats their natural treats from our
family to your best friend
and if you want any charlie bear
products just go to www.charliebear.com
and charlie is spelled
c-h-a-r-l-e-e-b-e-a-r
www.charliebear.com for more information
and if you want some of the delicious
hound gatos
food that my wonderful little blanche
eats just go to www.houndgatos.com
that's h-o-u-n-d-g-a-t-o-s
www.houndgatos.com
and don't forget your
www.charliebear.com for delicious treats
for your dogs
after the first one is you know they
didn't they try to cast
another actor as freddy krueger now this
would have just pissed me off lack of
respect
did they try because i know west didn't
direct the second one i know there
but the fact that they did did not ask
you to do the second one or that you
wanted to
they asked me to do it and now they're
i've heard there was a money thing but i
never remember
i don't remember there being a money
thing uh
i just remember there being a scheduling
thing and
because i had agreed on the money or my
agent had agreed on the money
he made demands with them about the
scheduling
and so they were going to use a double
for me for a scene in a steam room
so they used a double for me and i was
supposed to spark start the next day
and i literally remember being in makeup
late in the day like two in the
afternoon and they had finished with
the second day of using this double
and the director jack shoulder had gone
to bob shay
and the people and said we got to
reshoot this stuff with robert
it's horrible this guy's walking around
like frankenstein
you know and uh he did it's like we got
to do with robert he goes you don't know
and and so i really have to thank jack's
shoulder
for stopping shooting while i was
getting makeup in the makeup trailer
when i finally was scheduled i'd
finished whatever else i was doing some
other movie
and uh he brought me they brought me and
i and they were already a couple of days
into the shooting of the boys at the
high school
and uh brought me in and i was there
getting my makeup i think it was my fir
my one and only late call for makeup i
had up until that point
normally i'm there at the crack of dawn
and uh
i kinda i think i saw the other guy for
for a minute i saw them maybe they had a
mask on him or something i don't even
know if they had
the right makeup on him because they
hadn't designed any for him
and kevin yeager was the makeup guy for
part two the great kevin yeager who
produced sleepy hollow
yeah created chucky and everything else
and kevin yeager you know was there
putting on my makeup and he prepared it
so obviously we've been we've made the
deal because he'd had to do the
the molds and everything or he'd gotten
the molds from david miller and had done
all the sculpting
on the prosthetic pieces and uh it was a
it was finer and thinner
i remember i don't quite remember going
to kevin's shop but perhaps i did
before that i maybe i did go to go to
kevin's shop and do a test
but there had been that delay in
scheduling uh
but i really have jack's shoulder to
thank for being the guy
you know the director of part two saying
you gotta use robert there's nobody else
so there was no discrepancy there was no
not ever thinking of not
casting you in the second one because of
money or anything like that well they
offered me
i was offered the part and i don't think
it was money
because i i remember um i
was still perhaps i had just finished
the
the second or i was still doing the
series of v or i had just finished
the series of v and we were all sitting
around with our fingers crossed and it
would be picked up
and uh and and i had renegotiated and
that's where i was made you know that's
where i was making my big bucks right
uh i'm aaron elmster but you should have
been it was quite easy for me to say
oh they're offering you know this amount
fine
fine i'll do it you know but they have
to wait wait wait i'm done with the last
episode of my
of a v because then then i'll be on hold
for v
waiting to hear if i'm picked up and
we'll fit in nightmare and elsewhere and
they were all
they were kind of uppity about that but
yeah but robert i i feel like
i i i know i would have been and anybody
out listening would be like
i'm freddie [ __ ] krueger that movie
was
i'm fred krueger here so you have to pay
up
michael you have to understand back then
my head was in v
v was my international success they were
flying me over to italy for award shows
i think i'd already done one movie in
europe which i love i love working in
europe
in spain or somewhere and and i i love
playing freddy and i knew freddie was a
hit but there was only one freddy
and it had just begun to take off huge
internationally and because this would
have been 85
right and uh i my head was not just in
the freddy krueger
playbook i was still hoping
i'd get picked up for v because then i
would be rich right
and so i wasn't thinking about
negotiating my agent was just trying to
i think clear the schedule
make this gosh okay and not demand a
bunch of money that this wasn't where my
head was at
um again i'll even i'll tell you that at
the end
of nightmare two the one we're talking
about
i had to do pickup shots in a little mtv
studio on santa monica boulevard
in west hollywood and i just i think i
had to like you know peer around a door
or
i you know they saw me they saw my
shadow maybe a shot moving up my legs
and you saw me from down just a couple
of of of atmosphere
pickup shots and uh i they wes craven
loaned them the original glove
for the pickup shots and i went over
there and i've been told by somebody at
fango
to watch out for industrial espionage
of fanboys who were going to try to
steal some props
at this shoot and we realized there were
a couple of guys there on the crew that
weren't really on the crew
and the reason we i i d them was because
they had brand new
uh tool belts from walmart brand new you
know that new kind of timberland letter
that bright orangey leather you know
yeah you can tell you know that you know
like when you go to school the first day
after christmas the guy that has all the
new clothes on you know you can tell
he wasn't yeah it wasn't grip yeah
everything all the tools were shiny and
new you know he didn't have them in the
right loops
so we kind of figured out who these guys
were so i took the glove
i took the original glove and i just
gave it to my agent
as a present you know because i i didn't
think this nightmare on alma street
thing was going to be that big i figured
hey i got
i did two of them you know it's it's
helping me overseas
great you know i hadn't made a lot of
money i i thought it was going to be a
tv star
back then i thought oh i'm going to be
the new doctor's spock or something
right because of b and uh the next thing
i know you know i've got first class
tickets to paris
and first class tickets to hong kong and
all that stuff
wow kind of changed overnight for me and
then by the time
three came i i couldn't control it by
the time
the nightmare three came around uh which
was i think is the biggest hit
of all of them with patricia arquette
that's my favorite the original is my
favorite then
three i would say is is my second
favorite is the fan favorite
yeah three's definitely the fact it's
just the kids and you it's just
raven's new nightmare the best but oh
yeah that's fantastic it's
real kind of deconstructed you know
it's kind of meta yeah and fun
what did you you know a lot of people i
know you've heard this a million times
and you could like uh
denounce it or whatever but you know
they say that the second film
you know when you watch it there's a lot
of uh
you know undertones there are
sexual uh what what's the proper
terminology here well there's a subtext
let's let's call it like it is the
homosexual subtext of part two
the gay subtext is that
freddie is playing with the two boys
he's in their subconscious
mark patton and robert rustler freddy's
in their heads
they're having freddy nightmares so he's
playing with them he's toying
with their adolescent hormones and any
latent
homosexuality that might be present in
either of them so that's there we played
with that
and freddie plays with it there's a
scene where i you know i
i i circle the boy's mouth with my blade
and practically french kissing right
i remember talking to mark and going
mark was i'm going to make this real
darkly erotic here we we were on top
jack was so busy
worrying about the effects and the money
and that constantly tick-tock clock
going you know when you're shooting
the jack doesn't remember you know that
we played with that but i know mark and
i talked about i think
robert russell and i talked about bob
shay i think on the interviews he would
say like no i don't remember anything
like i think he was the one
bob doesn't remember talking about it
because we were so worried about you
know getting
you know we shot in pasadena if you know
anything about shooting in pasadena
you got to have everything rolled up and
out of town by 10 30 at night although
you know it's a huge fine
right they had a lot of pressure on them
but bob shea
plays an s m bartender in the s m
g marketing oh that's right
nice
there's definitely it's not you know
there's and we right away
you know i right away i was getting all
his fan mail from kids that
loved you know sin and mark patton was
getting hurt
from from from boys and girls that were
saying we oh we like seeing ourselves
you know we're troubled and
all of that and confusing you know and
and
so we played it it was just it was just
one more
element yeah to sink your teeth into it
it's amazing
what the movie's about but it is a
subject
it's amazing that i as a kid when i
watched it it
you know it scared the [ __ ] out of me
and i didn't recognize any of that and
then when i watched it as an adult i go
oh my gosh
look at the door it says keep out the
boys if you watch
any of them there's some there's sexual
stuff at all
oh yeah oh yeah freddie you know there's
a beauty in the beast
sexuality hidden there that's not always
part of it
but it's not you know the the thing that
that people get wrong
is imagining that that freddie is a
pedophile no no no freddie
freddie's a child killer you want to
think of that poetically
darkly poetic like like a like a a doors
song
you know jim morrison's classic cover of
child killer
you know alice cooper a child killer you
know or somebody
it's it's that darkly child killer has a
thing to it
he's killing the future children of the
future he's killing the future
dark and william blake and and creepy
and dark about that
you know so he's killing kids he doesn't
he doesn't need to rape him
you know isn't that bad enough that he's
killing him yeah
yeah that's bad enough i i you know by
the way your energy it's like i i'm back
on set an urban legend with you you just
had that lovable
fun you know just your great storyteller
and i appreciate a fan too
you know we talk about i mean you and i
remember you and i bonded over movies we
love that oh yeah
oh yeah and i wanna bond with you again
we gotta we gotta catch up for real i
mean this is this is uh enormous for me
i love this i've always wanted to have
you
and the the fans my patrons out there
they're gonna love this
by the way this is this is called [ __ ]
talking with robert england and this is
rapid fire see answer these real quick
from from fans
okay rapid fire taylor k what was the
most difficult scene to film in the
nightmare and elm street franchise
um probably uh
the the demon freddy uh in in uh
freddie versus jason i'm a little over
the hill
when i did that movie i had to do my
sit-ups every morning and uh eat my
yogurt and my gluten-free
uh and i that's really me underwater in
that movie and that's me coming out
wow and landing on the deck of the pier
but i couldn't get that makeup off
because they double glued me uh
on the demon makeup and they were
worried that i'd leak like an old condom
you know
and uh i'd look like a water balloon or
something after one take
so they double glued me and we couldn't
get that off
and it took hours ago i was rubbed and
scrubbed and scrubbed and by then i'm
raw
and i had to go back to work the next
morning at dawn to put the traditional
freddy makeup
on and uh that was a [ __ ] of a week
thank god i had a break coming up on
friday steph a as the king of nightmares
have you ever had a real nightmare that
scared you
yeah yeah yeah i i have one for years
when i was a child and and i i had it in
the adolescence where
uh it sort of pork chop hill meets
manchurian candidate you know
the traditional uh korean war
the korean soldier north korean soldier
they have that
that that hat you know with the with the
flaps pinned up
and the red star so that scared me to
death it's a cold war fear i guess from
watching the the news or something but
i'm
on a playground i'm a child i'm in
elementary school
and i'm in the lap of the most beautiful
girl in the sixth grade
and i'm dying and she's caressing me and
blood's coming out of the corner of my
mouth
and over the fence of the playground are
all
of these north korean soldiers with guns
and fur coats and those those those hats
with the red star and the ear flaps
pinned up
coming at me and i ha i don't know what
it's from or where it's from but i had
that probably until i was 20 years old
don't eat before you go to bed
and i i wrote about it in my book and i
mentioned the girl's name
and about five years ago i got in i got
an email from her
the girl that this girl from my sixth
grade class
wow what does it mean i don't know man
that's in dreams
i swear to god i i'm not even being
weird but i had a dream that you came
over my house instead of zoomed me
and you were in in makeup but you were
it was really bad makeup and i'm like
well you know you don't have to be in
makeup for the interview
and then you're like no it's fine it's
fine and you're looking at my [ __ ] and
you're
it was just weird i don't i don't know
anyway carly t you have played freddie
across various platforms
what's your favorite version of freddie
to play you said the fourth one do you
like but
therefore the one ready harlan directed
i i he let me kind of physicalize it
and dance him a little more right i
really like my performance
lauren w do you still have the iconic
red and blue sweater no way
no way no i gave it to uh uh
planet hollywood for their big opening
and they shut down yeah it must be in
bruce willis attic now or his ass
somewhere in idaho little lisa what was
your favorite part about working on
urban legend besides working with me
well i did like those lunches with baron
munchausen
you know with john nelson john neville
those were fun plus
i got to i got to act with alicia witt
and i've had such a crush
you have does nancy know this i don't
know i don't know
she does now late in life i got a little
tingle for redheads
i never had it now now i'll be flipping
around the tv
i see an old rhonda fleming movie and i
get a heart on it i mean i don't
understand
well just late in life well ruski s
rusky speaking of ruski oh ruski over
there rusky yes did you
you ad-lib any of the great one-liners
he already told us his story but what's
your what's your favorite one-liner
well i like welcome to prime time [ __ ]
but there's one in freddy versus jason
where he says don't worry princess the
first time
tends to get a little messy
i remember that good god leanne p
i love your portrayal of willy and one
of my all-time favorite mini-series v
of course any fun memories you'd like to
share from behind the scenes
well you know i'm always brokenhearted
that we got prematurely cancelled when
we turn to series
one night we were working on the backlot
of warner brothers and we had
uh uh trash barrels with little fires in
them
kind of like a homeless encampment
and we were all sitting around warming
our hands and doing this scene
and i went over and i saw that the
dailies the next day
and it was nighttime and we're all lit
underneath with the flames and i said
this
is what the show should look like
because they tried to play the normalcy
of the earth being kind of invaded and
held
captive by these aliens and i love the
idea of the underground and the rebels
kind of having to like live by their
wits and
and living underground and this idea of
of
like these sort of like uh homeless
camps
and the the fires in trash cans
and skulking around at night it just i
went oh my god this was probably
halfway into the series you know cost
nothing would you
just shoot nights and make it look now
we've seen that post-apocalyptic look on
everything
right now but back then in the early 80s
this was a great look
and we could have embraced that i think
along with the leftover
john dykstra creations and it would have
been a better look for the series
lisa h what was it like working with
andrew dice clan the adventures of ford
fairline your character in that movie
made her laugh
out loud hello hello hello
snapper andrew used
my first gourmet market uh chalet
gourmet on the corner of uh
sunset boulevard in fairfax and
i i almost scratched andrew's cadillac
opening the door there once and andrew
went off on me in character
you know he was smoking a cigarette in
the parking lot and then cut to
years later i'm working with andrew and
uh and he remembered it you know
and he kind of he was really sweet you
know he kind of apologized he said i was
in a bad mood i just lost a part
but i remember when andrew bought his
first uh you know his first house
and he was signing the papers in his uh
dressing room and he was nervous he was
like a big kid
you know he's he really is a teddy bear
in in real life
but you know i remember nora norah dunn
you know oh yeah
and complaining about him and we you as
a comic and me as an actor knowing
other actors source material i always
knew
that that he was doing a little bit of
buddy love
and a little bit of fonzarelli you know
he was doing a little bit of lords of
flat bush he was doing
buddy joey butterfucko he was doing
those long island guys
you and i know that and for her not to
see that
and to think that was andrew you know it
kind of broke my heart that it
took the wind out of his career for a
while but he's had the last lap said
that hbo show
did that great woody allen movie with
cate blanchett i remember he uh
cried on arsenio hall i think it was he
was like you know people
you know they think that i'm this way
you know you know he starts talking
about that
but he had the best one-liners this guy
in the audience was hacking we don't
need people like you
get out of here and he just looks and
goes why don't you turn your teeth
around
and bite your throat do us all a favor
you
[ __ ] and he goes hey you're the
look at you you're the type of guy that
gets out of the shower to take a piss
i just loved him i mean i just a sweet
guy
he didn't mean that [ __ ] he was just
working he was a character well any star
[ __ ] at all on board fairly
that you know that movie didn't do that
well when it came out but now it's
and you know you've had something like
this dude it's great it's full-fledged
cult classic now
yeah hey last week yes gilbert gottfried
you know vince neil from motley crew
i mean everybody and their dog is in
that i remember being in the capitol
records building
sitting with uh priscilla presley
and wayne newton and he had the left
fret left-handed a stratocaster
of uh uh jimi hendrix and
and wayne newton is a huge rock
encyclopedia
he knows everything about rock and roll
everybody he's met everybody he's mr las
vegas
and he was telling stories about elvis
and literally playing chords
on the jimi hendrix stratocaster and he
and priscilla are old friends
and you know it's like you're like whoa
and then we went
to roast joel silver in vegas at a roast
and i got to walk through the casino
with
the king of las vegas's wife priscilla
presley on one hand
and and and wayne newton mr las vegas on
the other
and the casino parted
like the red sea you know the ten
commandments
and people came up and they had you know
priscilla kiss her
kiss their dice you know not andrew dice
clay but
you know they're craps yeah and they
also had uh you know they they just
wanted to touch them for good luck
that was all because you know of andrew
dice clay in his movie joel silver
produced it
you know harlan also directed that by
the directive part four
but uh that was just a a a really fun
gig
i did all my own stunts on that too
that's me and the sinking boat
you know it's really it's yours truly i
love it hey let me ask you lastly before
we go i should have maybe this shouldn't
be the last question but
you know i worked with wes uh we did a
movie that nobody saw really called
kirsten
i just i really loved him he sent me a
letter before i worked with him just
i still have the letter about just just
saying i love your work and i'd love for
you to
come and join us it was just but when he
passed away it broke my heart i felt
so horrible about it but i know that you
you knew him for so many years
were you guys close and did it how did
it affect you
we were close and we had mutual respect
uh
you know wes is a double threat writer
director which
you always feel comfortable with that
and uh
i did a series for wes up in vancouver
uh and uh
we were watching snl one night i had the
best apartment
up by stanley park because i might walk
my dog in stanley park
and we were watching snl and it was the
night of the
head wound harry sketch with dana
and uh wes and uh uh
myself my wife a couple of the actors
from the show were all sitting around
drinking a bottle of wine
and headroom harry came on and wes
is very tall you know and wes is sitting
on my couch and wes
almost fell off the couch laughing he
was laughing so hard he was crying and
he turned into
the 14 year old boy that is wes loving
that dark
funny tricky humor that head wound harry
was
and uh i mean i had to like slap him on
the back because he was
he was laughing so hard we thought he
was to choke and
les had let down his hair so to speak in
front of me that night
got a little drunk you know and and
laughed until he was crying at that
sketch
and and and i think he that was kind of
my gift from wes
that he finally became one of the guys
with ball instead of just my boss you
know he was one of the guys finally
that's amazing yeah he uh i remember he
again he used to always have me do
impressions for takes and the cast was
were
they're just like so they had to redo
this movie curse so they redid it they
wanted him to reshoot it which he was so
pissed off about it
and uh the actors had to come back but
they recast a couple actors and
he asked me and you know it wasn't even
a huge part but i just wanted to work
with wes i just didn't care and every
day he would just have me
michael do it like walking do it like
malkovich do it like and the cast was
like tired but they were like kind of
trying to be nice but i'm like are you
sure
he's like yes and so i was barely in the
movie and then when we had a wrap party
on the video i was like 80 of it i'm a
guy that worked like six days on the
movie
and he he was just so at the end of it
we used to talk about amityville
he goes it was a hoax i'm like no it
wasn't we would talk about it right up
till we're shooting and we would
just he was so fun to be around and at
the end i go
wes he goes michael i go it's great
working with you it's like
my pleasure it was a real pleasure and i
go i'm gonna give you a hug now he goes
are you sure
and i go if you if you don't mind he
goes
okay we gave each other this nice hug
and it was just i just loved i wanted
he's one of those guys where you want
him to like you you just
you just he's such a good spirit to be
around
a lot of people don't know i don't know
if he ever went up to his house
he had the coolest the coolest bachelor
pad
in all of l.a he lived in steve
mcqueen's
old bachelor pad and he'd retooled it he
had a
you know an exercise pool and
everything in it was cool every coffee
table book
every every cd line around the art on
the walls it was just the coolest place
right on a cliff way up nichols canyon
overlooking you can see catalina island
so there's that part of wes
he also when i first met him at his
first house down in venice
he had great some great cars original
xke
you know peter o'toole audrey hepburn
you know uh
you know how to seal a million xke in
his garage
um but there's also the wes craven that
as a child was not allowed you know to
read comic books or go to movies
or watch tv he could only see like a
couple of disney movies a year
so wes was always kind of catching up
you could always turn wes on to some
movie or
or or you know some horror movie great
classic
or or something kind of grind house
quentin tarantino asks
or or or something like that because he
sort of missed that as a child
because his parents wouldn't let he and
his brother see that stuff
wow yeah hunger he had that hunger and
that curiosity
and i think he also because of that he
sort of kept the 14 year old boy alive
in him
yeah hey i love you it's so great to
see you and hear from you and thank you
for being on the on the podcast
my pleasure michael hey be careful out
there all right
we'll all see each other at a con soon
i love that interview i really enjoy
he's just so open and i think you know
when you play a character for so long
you know you can get tired of the same
old questions and yeah i try to mix it
up but
uh it's so iconic and you know my
friends and i we actually sat down and
watched all the nightmare in elm streets
yeah it was a good time it was a good
time they're not all good i'll tell you
that
there's a lot of them they can't all be
yeah no they can't be there's there's a
couple of them that i really liked but
um dream warriors was my favorite the
first one
dream warriors was really good but uh
thank you robert england for coming on
the podcast it meant a lot to me and i
uh
i consider you an old friend and uh
yeah if you enjoyed that stick around
please subscribe to the podcast
take a listen for next week's episode
it's going to be another goodie
and um yeah thank you to all the patrons
again if you want to um
follow us on socials uh inside of youpod
on in twitter no not inside to be
podcast on instagram and facebook at
inside of you pod on twitter and
that inside you podcast on instagram and
facebook and then if you want to watch
on youtube just type in inside you with
michael rosenbaum you can watch the
interviews
sometimes we do these cool animations
the one that came out of
kiefer sutherland and really good ones
jason patrick they did a great job
they really did a great job and that's
on your instagram and that's on my
instagram you can go to the real
no it's just the michael rosenbaum on
instagram but thank you to everybody
remember
sun spin go to sunspin.com for all band
updates you want to book a zoom with us
you want to
book the band you want to get merch you
want to go to a sunspin listen to a
sunspin show or watch it on
stage it on may 29th 2pm 6pm we'd love
to support
if you haven't we'd really love to to
see you there and see your name pop up
and i'll give you a shout out
um and if you want to join patreon if
you want to join patreon
uh with many other people it's become a
nice family please do so
at patreon.com inside of you
and join us and i'll give you a nice
text right after and it's uh there's a
lot of fun stuff on the patreon
if you don't know what it is check it
out go to patreon.com inside of you and
you can
learn because it will show you what
different tiers get and
uh again you know boxes for me and
messages and this and that and
it's uh it's a lot of fun but right now
one of my favorite parts
of the podcast is the end of the podcast
which i get to give all the shout outs
to the patrons and we get to see how
many uh names ryan knows
yeah here we go nancy d mary
b leah s trisha
f sarah v little lisa
you kiko jill e brian
h lauren g nico
p robin s
jerry w robert
w no gosh you just
robert l no it's robert b it's it's did
you guys got to give it up write in to
ryan what's your twitter
is ryan ryan at t-e-l-l-e-z
ryan and give him a shout out for it's
pretty amazing that he could do this
we got jason w we got a puffy and we got
kristen k amelia oh allison l
lucas m raj c joshua d emily s cj
he samantha m jennifer n
jackie p stacy l carly p
h wow you're baffling me carly asked jen
s jamal f janelle b carrie b tablet 272
not to be confused with
the 273 ashley ryan kimberly mike e
marissa
and naniarello eldon sopramo 99
more ramirez santiago m sarah f chad w
leanne p
ray h a oh that's a first maya
p maddie s kendrick f dude how are you
doing this because i've done
60 of these ashley uh
e e sure shannon d matt w belinda and
kevin v
james r chris h dave h samantha f
spider-man
chase sheila g ray h tabitha
t tom and yeah
suzanne p b
katie i don't know f
liliana a michelle k hannah b michael s
talia m
luke h andrew t betsy declare m
liz j laura l chad l rochelle e
le final stretch nathan
i don't know e brandel taylor k neil a
marion a
meg k janelle p trav l dan n
jennifer j wayne m diane r
o chetta lorraine
g olga okay oh wait no that's a person
c cory m carrie h
veronica k big stevie w kendall t
lindsey m carroll d kdg uh we got sandy
b angel m eric c rhiannon c stephen
m corey k super sam super sam
emily k sherry s coleman g michelle a
and riley j it means the world that you
guys
are uh my top tiers and that you listen
to show and subscribe and all that stuff
and i would not
be able to do this without you that's a
fact i told you before
thanks for subscribing i love you from
ryan tears and michael rosenbaum up here
in the hills of hollywood
hollywood california everybody it's
harry
carey here and we're gonna wave to the
camera ryan
hey guys thank you for allowing me to be
inside each and every one of you i hope
you have a glorious week
and thank you for allowing me to be a
part of your life every day
or at least once a week when you listen
to the podcast so
uh take care of yourselves be good to
yourselves be good to others
and much love